hi there Rick nicholsby Channel 6 News
we've had reports of a Pegasus in the
area has anybody seen anything like that
oh yeah man I've seen the packages I've
seen it yeah every
dude man
yeah I started with my own two eyes man
that horse had a big old snake head on
top of it ain't got no snake head fool
yeah hey that horse had some big wings
man yeah yeah yeah big old wins man like
two sets of wings yeah man y'all
everybody
[Applause]
babies
dude I am sorry we're late man it
happens man she talk about how we're
supposed to be in the car at 6 45 I'm
like all right
tell me my dumb ass ain't sitting in the
car waiting until 7 15. okay when I
track my wife down 20 minutes later
she's stepping out the damn shower
talking about can I help you see that's
crazy right there Craig I looked this
woman in the eye I said
[__] you told me 6 45. you said that
yeah I said
[__] then I'll laid it out but you said
[__] though
hmm he said [__]
yeah
don't play games man
it's like say what you mean mean what
you say is that so hard it's like last
week man we going out to dinner right
I'm like where do you want to go she's
like you decide oh I'm like all right
Outback Steakhouse she like nah like
straight up Chili's she's like no no
Daryl I named seven more wrestlers no
Craig no he finally said Taylor's the
place I know she wants to go out in the
first place right right she look at me
she said if that's where you want to go
no she didn't because that's where I
want to go Daryl I looked my woman in
the eye sockets I told her straight out
I just said it man I said it I said I
said I said
baby I'm gonna take her back up to the
kitchen and show her the dishwasher
hey Daryl yeah baby I want a kitchen
island just like the one upstairs you're
gonna get it too
I love you
I said
[__] if you wanted to go to Taylor's
just tell her brother you want to go
with Taylor you said that oh hell yeah
man I laid it out right I said I said I
said
I said
[__] I'm the man of the house you say a
[__] though you caught your wife a
[__]
oh yeah
Daryl where are those guys
so she's like why don't you rent a movie
we both like no she did after I spent 25
minutes in the goddamn block Mr Craig I
looked this woman in her optic spam and
I said I said
you said that ain't nothing but a thing
but you said [__] though
yep
oh
hey honey Craig just give me the
neighborhood tour
so then she's like I didn't know we'd be
doing so much walking no uh I'm like I
didn't tell you to wear those shoes she
said don't raise your voice at me what
dare roll
I'll look this woman dead in the windows
of her soul
I said
[Music]
thank you
I said me
[__]
all right y'all gather round gather
round welcome gentlemen what up
beautiful and blessed day for an auction
all right y'all get on up there
I don't care what Plantation I end up on
I'm straight staging a Revolt in this
[__] Hells yeah we have lot a
lot B and Lot C three dollars on lot a
four dollars five five dollars going
once twice three times sold laude goes
to the man and the black
I mean good yeah I'm glad I didn't get
sold because I don't want to be owned by
another human being whoever buys me they
better kill me the first day I'm gonna
go buck wild on the whole operation next
one get up on up there now
oh it's okay
six dollars on lot a seven dollars eight
nine nine dollar going once twice three
times sold
okay well you have to buy it out there
it's a no-brainer I mean that guy's a
huge massive individuals that's two of
me anybody would buy him I'd buy that
dude my question is how did they catch
him next
okay
two dollars on lot a two dollars going
once twice three times sold see now that
surprises me that is interesting to say
the least I mean well it just seems like
at a certain point it's like do they
even know what they're looking at it's
like the whole criteria seems a little
inconsistent I mean at some point I want
to be online
next
up oh here we go here we go good
pleasure give him hell all right okay
eight dollars on lot a going once twice
three tops hold
not true
that can't be true because what can you
do look at him what could he pick a
cotton plan is like this town yes I'm
saying you know offense brother I'm just
saying oh since taken what
Am I Wrong is he's not shorty shorts but
you are actually short in real life in
the world you're good man enough
I will not have my reputation tainted
selling superficial bigoted slaves
superficial did that really just come
out of your mouth that's it this
auction's over auction's over no it
ain't over it's not over well I'm strong
y'all I'm very sure I can sleep in a
bucket I'm fast I got stamina no I don't
look at me no magic my worst quality is
that I'm a perfectionist have I
mentioned this docile I am agreeable to
a fault you should have seen the dude
who asked me to get on the boat when we
came over he got a violent
no big deal never seen a boat in my life
good evening my fellow Americans now
before I begin
I just want to say that I know a lot of
people out there seem to think that I
don't get angry
that's just not true I get angry a lot
it's just the way I express passion is
different from most
so just so there's no more confusion
we've hired Luther here to be my anger
translator Luther hi
first off concerning the recent
developments in the Middle Eastern
region I just want to reiterate our
unflinching support for all people and
their right to a democratic process hey
all y'all dictators out there keep
messing around and see what happens just
see what happens watch also to the
governments of Iran and North Korea we
once again urge you to discontinue your
uranium enrichment program hey Mahmoud
Kim Jong I think I already Untold both
y'all 86 [__] I'm gonna come over
there and do it for y'all please test me
and see what happens on the domestic
front
I just want to say to my critics I hear
your voices and I'm aware of your
concerns so maybe you could chill the
hell out for like a second then maybe I
could
do some [__]
Michael's for everybody
including members of the Tea Party oh
don't even get me started on these
mothers right here I want to assure you
that we will be looking for new
compromises with the GOP and La Monster
Health you know these gonna say no
before I even see Jesse no I know a lot
of folks say that I haven't done a good
job at communicating my accomplishments
to the public
uh
since being in office we've created
three million new jobs 3 million
we ended the war in Iraq
in a wharf is a reminder that I am on
your side
and that my intentions as your president
are coming from the right place they're
coming from Hawaii which is where I'm
from which is in the United States of
America y'all okay this is ridiculous I
have a birth certificate I have a birth
certificate I have a hot diggity
Microsoft birth certificate you dumbass
crackers okay Luther yeah dial it back
Luther damn in conclusion
last night I had a conversation with
Michelle
nope I did not say that I did not say
that this is Whitaker I have been
babysitting for 20 years I've seen it
all the thing is uh Forest is a unique
child everything is going to be fine I
want you to have a good time tonight you
deserve it
okay um
good luck thank you
go Gaga
oh
hey there Forest
I want
I want milk
you want me to get your your bottle
buddy I wanna milk okay
[Music]
this is a baba
I want Mama's milk
why can't I have Mama's milk
[Music]
simple request yeah well uh you should
you can't have Mama's milk right now
buddy um how about we play
okay I want
I won I wanna play with my Legos okay
yeah okay buddy let's suck your Legos
then
I wanna
I wanna put the smallest Lego in my
mouth that's what I'm gonna do no no you
can't you can't do that what
first you tell me I can't have Mama's
milk now you have a smallest Lego in my
mouth
what a night this is a bad start right
but before it's dangerous let me get
this straight you're in charge of me in
my house all right Forest it's time for
bed I guess then
you gonna sing me a song
what mom always sing me a song before I
go to sleep
are you gonna do that for me
okay okay yeah yes I will
hush little baby don't say a word
keep keep singing mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird put my name in it I like I
like it personal hush baby Forest
Whitaker don't say a word
mom's gonna buy you a mockingbird a
babysitter and if that mockingbird don't
sing have a good cry
Obama's gonna buy you retirement
[Music]
Drew come forward
your Chef this is a chicken quiche with
cremini mushrooms baby spinach and feta
cheese
foreign
[Music]
I have a huge problem with this dish
it's that you haven't made it for me
sooner
thank you chef
because if you had Drew then I would
know how good you are at cooking food
that's bad
I'm sorry sir when I say bad I'm a
Michael Jackson Bad
thank you Chef you know how we look
really really bad at the end of his life
I'm sorry I don't know if you like the
dish or not you don't know if I locked
the dish or not well let's put it this
way Pat your [__] knives get out
you're off the show sorry sure
because
you should be working in the finest
restaurants in the world
thank you Chef just not any world that I
live in
because frankly it drew I'm jealous of
you thank you sir and your ability to
not give a [__] about what you cook this
is not fit for human consumption no this
should be eaten by a higher life form
with a more complex palette but also an
altruistic drive to save Humanity from
dishes like this joking not you deserve
to die
so you won't have to endure a life in
which you will never exceed what you
have achieved here today
[Applause]
thank you Sean
[Music]
in conclusion
oh this is one of our come on man what
you doing man that's stupid
that's stupid man don't do that man come
on
are you kidding me come on man don't go
in there do not go into a crane shot
right now you kidding me yeah man hell
yeah this movie's got an inconsistent
visual language half the time this just
shooting all handheld like your Dogma
filmmaker that's funny says Dogma
clearly forbids temporal and
geographical alienation
oh I love that shot the first time when
it was in nosferatos that's right I mean
he's trying to do some homage to the
German expression this is something it's
a visual medium man enough with this My
Dinner with Andre I mean has this dude
even heard of his own song put some
information up in the frame [__] oh I
get it yeah imma overexpose the film
getting a fairy look man [__] this can
we just go come on they're actually
making good points
hey has this guy
too much Quentin Tarantino or what
or what are your boys too much talking
okay
[Music]
he's not gonna bother you anymore
thank you
[Music]
what do we do
they told us at the station to come down
here and fill time but uh there's no
story here
in this neighborhood there's always a
story here give me the name of a
mythical creature mythical I don't trust
me uh I don't know a Pegasus Pegasus
perfect just roll watch and learn
but he can stay in my house if they want
to hi there Rick nicholsby Channel 6
News we've had reports of a Pegasus in
the area has anybody seen anything like
that oh yeah man I've seen the Pegasus
I've seen it yeah every day I need to do
man we both seat that package here I
started with my own two eyes man that
horse had a big old snake head on top of
it ain't got no snake head fool yeah
that horse had some big wings man
big old wins man like two sets of wings
received
Curiosity has brought out large crowds
to see the alleged Pegasus in this South
Lenox neighborhood oh look there it is
I'm gonna find it
break it
and then ride it to the Pegasus treasure
residents say the creature resembles
this amateur sketch kick the
City's gotta pay for that too I ain't
got no coverage with no packages [__]
he landed on my roof man look at my roof
man he busted it up he busted the whole
thing up man yeah he been he been
sitting up there every day while many
Revel in the possibility of seeing the
winged horse others are not so welcoming
I just know this neighborhood will be
better if that Pegasus is put down I
tell you this God ain't putting no wings
on no horse now see if this was a white
neighborhood Animal Control would be up
in here with a pegasus trapped that's
right they can't take off Pegasus this
is all Pegasus yeah
hey man why are you interrupting me I'm
trying to talk about the Pegasus [__]
you hey don't be disrespecting practices
[Music]
yes we're here live on the scene in
South London where riots have broken out
over the alleged appearance of a flying
horse
[Music]